iban a ser solo tres días pero ahora el
gasoducto nordstring 1 que transporta
gas ruso a Europa quedará cerrado
indefinidamente Por culpa de unas
reparaciones
así lo informaba al gigante energético
gasprom según la información de siemens
la eliminación completa de las fugas de
aceite en estos motores solo es posible
en las condiciones de un taller de
reparación hasta que no se eliminen las
advertencias sobre el funcionamiento de
los equipos el transporte de gas al
gasoducto northream estará completamente
parado
Rusia alega que las sanciones europeas
por la guerra en Ucrania impiden hacerle
buen mantenimiento al gasoducto que ya
estaba parado Desde hace dos días
también debido a su puesta reparaciones
disminuyendo así significativamente la
cantidad de gas que llega a Alemania y
se distribuye por el resto de países
europeos y encareciendo todavía más los
precios de la electricidad en los países
del bloque comunitario
con la interrupción total anunciada este
viernes la situación solo puede empeorar
la Unión Europea sigue afirmando que
Rusia usa su gas como venganza contra el
apoyo occidental a Ucrania
el anuncio de gasprom de esta tarde
sobre el nuevo cierre del North Stream 1
bajo argumentos falaces es otra
confirmación de su poca fiabilidad como
proveedor también demuestra el cinismo
de Rusia que prefiere quemar gas a
honrar sus contratos el nuevo órdago
ruso llega Precisamente en el momento en
el que los líderes europeos se preparan
para limitar los precios de la energía
una estrategia que ayudaría a su
población a sobrellevar la crisis que se
avecina pero que reduciría los ingresos
rusos